welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and we finally
have our first official look at the
gameplay for Marvel's Avengers
throughout this video I'll be playing
the official demo footage that was
released and giving my thoughts on it
and what it means for the overall game
before we get started I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into the gameplay
and then I'll give my thoughts on the
entire thing
never meet your heroes
well I did
and it was awesome
The Avengers were everything I imagined
hello San Francisco Thor Tony check it
out that's once
yeah obviously figured I'd let you catch
up whoa this just got a whole lot more
interesting let's make this quick
see if you can clear a path on the
bridge
[Music]
shoot not would door what's your status
they're immortal you should have had a
bigger breakfast this morning
Thor thanks for the assist
you got civilians trapped behind those
barricades understood stay behind me
I'll deal with them
this should be fun
[Music]
please are you hurt no just stop lucky
for you I am mighty Thank You Thor get
to sing help is on the way
whoa whoa Thunder God and you could have
all the fun
your turn
[Music]
got admitted that was pretty impressive
cocky like that
[Music]
it's coming
see quick
none over dark
hey get back here
just got confirmation a shield convoy
was hijacked this morning mr. one of
Fury's boarding three side never read
come on Tony
those are important okay whatever
Crockett's collects fury kept all my
fifth tech in one place those rockets
are going to destabilize the fringe yeah
I know I build the damn things
have you should secure the Terrigen
crystal if that thing gets it already on
it
they buy cover all right which one of
you be movie extras shot at me
the Colliers carry us to fight field
turning down the full memory I really
love being shot at my old weapon we'll
keep you updated
hey didn't know you were listening that
Niki's cities he's running away by can't
shake the feeling we're playing catch-up
something else going on here
go on down there Tony nothing
everything's Just Peachy just hoping
these guys don't have
let's take it back they've got post our
test
[Music]
going for a ride cap someone's initiated
the security protocols the chimeras
autopilot has taken over smells like a
heist we're heading back negative
secure the bridge those weapons can't
get into the city copy that
you're up Bruce yeah
[Music]
some of the fires on me annoying little
guy darnay's on my way
no I was thinking today's tip if you
want fan clubs and funnel cakes
Tony
[Music]
we don't take them out
hurry up big guy can't take much more
punishment
big green I got eyes on him hook
bringing in the quinjets out laughing
[Music]
inventions are dangerous stock a those
weapons were meant for the good guys is
that supposed to be a joke not the time
get your heads in the game cap what's
going on over there
not sure nut seems like the reactor is
malfunctioning I'm getting strange
readings on the monitors like we're
being pulled to a heat signal in the bay
now that's going to destroy this repeat
that crap I'm having trouble hearing
Matt do you read
all heads the chimera is under attack
evacuate the civilians
[Music]
do you read
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
captain we have a problem the reactor
won't stabilize Terrigen molecular
structure into breaking down into a gas
it's extraordinary
if you can't fix the rock and get to
safety
Shepard
if you can hear me the convoy is
transporting a highly lethal sonic
disrupter bomb on enemies intended
detonated within the city secure the
asset at once
no sonic bomb are you kidding me
thought the UN outlawed those years ago
let's have a look shall we
[Music]
now that is an entrance
[Music]
taskmaster
we need to get that detonator that bomb
goes off but could liquify everything
within a ten-mile radius
the cables
romanov from one former SHIELD agent to
another
masters you get a haircut
the bridge is secure
guys I'm getting these three seismic
readings
take this
you know I was hoping to fix you
doesn't matter I have this dammit
hand it over
come & get it
taking your usual notes right it's
called photographic reflexes
I've always wondered what it would feel
like to kill an Avenger keep wondering
yeah cat so you stolen your weapons from
shield
[Music]
your test ends now
must be frustrating always one step
behind you're gonna do with it sell it
to the highest bidder I'm after
something much more value
where is your investigation left you
you're not the brains behind this and
this smells like distraction I'm done
talking coward
what's the matter don't like surprises
cool lalla death can't learn what you
can't see
[Music]
next time guess you saw that coming huh
you think you've won what the hell are
you talking about look around Rome
enough the world will remember this day
the day their heroes failed them
what's happening here
[Music]
he's collapsing
damnit Plato's Steve can you hear me
get the hell out of there
[Music]
some say they were set up others call
them murderers do the Avengers pose a
danger to society that was the question
Bruce that was the question well we all
lost something that day but that's not
how this story ends
[Music]
okay so right off the bat I think that
this game looks like it's gonna knock it
out the park I really just wish that
Square Enix had have shown us this
footage earlier as I think it would have
silenced a lot of the criticism that
sprung up in the beginning it does look
absolutely phenomenal though with every
character really having their own
completely unique combat style that
embraces the best aspects of the
characters I know it's an obvious thing
to pick up on but Hulk controlled
completely different to Black Widow Thor
feels like he's got his own style and
Iron Man well he just looks incredible
it comes across like you're almost
playing as a jeer at some points and it
completely nails the aesthetic now the
game definitely borrows a lot from God
of War especially in the Thor sections
but if it's taking from games then
that's certainly a good one to pick you
really get the feeling that this is an
established team that will work together
to take on any threat and it's clear
that even if you don't like a character
you won't be playing as them too long to
really get tired of it and there's
always something right around the corner
that will switch things up this is a
really incredible looking game and I'm
very excited for it now there's a real
sense of momentum to the entire demo
where each character is constantly
pushing forward fighting their way to
the middle of the bridge it all ends in
tragedy - which is really refreshing to
see when dealing with heroes as these
guys win so often that it's great to see
them knocked back and infinite you all
really stride with this and in my
opinion became the best MCU film because
of it now there are certain things in
the demo that also highlight how the
game will be and what story beats that
will be with it it looks like this is
taking place in the same universe as the
spider-man ps4 game as in that there was
lip service paid to the fact the
Avengers were out west which is where
San Francisco is located in relation to
America taskmaster though a quite big
part of the demo I don't think will be
the main threat and it's clearly
something else going on here though we
don't know for definite yet domination
is being confirmed and the Terrigen mist
is massively apart of the Inhumans
universe in the graphic novel infinity
this is unleashed on
earth due to Attilan being destroyed by
Thanos and blackballed and this almost
crushes New York similar to how San
Francisco gets destroyed in this footage
there's also a possibility that the game
will center around age of Ultron and in
the comic book Ultron took over the
world and the Avengers travel back in
time to rewrite the past which may
happen in this game as Captain America
is dead and the majority of the world is
a completely different landscape I kind
of get the feeling that this may be the
basis for the game though it's complete
speculation I'd be very surprised though
if Captain America stayed dead
especially with how fully fleshed out
his combat looks
there's also drones in the trailer
machines and space so yeah I think it
could travel that route either way this
game is definitely shaping up to be
incredible they've completely nailed the
look of it and with the tease of
characters like Miss Marvel and so on
it's clear that they're looking to
expand the cast in this game we see her
breathe in the territory mist which can
transform people and I think this would
be the route that they traveled down in
the series overall a massively hard to
see what Square deliver and are
pre-ordered
yes pre-ordered the game based off this
footage which I'm sure is what they were
after
so yeah job well done they killed it and
I can't wait to play it obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
footage and if you're going to pre-order
the game or wait till you see more
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
all the rumors around the next big
Avengers movie which would be linked at
the end if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books then you can follow me on twitter
at definition whitey so the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see it over there
after this also just want to let you
know that we're giving away a free copy
of John wick 3 on blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the gameplay
footage in the comment section below the
wooden will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then whoever gets
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it's a
crime thanks again for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]